g'day everyone welcome to sumsup today
we're going to talk about the main event
that occurred in the world of cyber
security this month on august 5th apple
announced the new features of its ios
15. the most controversial of these
relates to apple's expanded protections
for children an algorithm that will
analyze photos on your phone in search
of illegal pornographic content and this
has caused some heated debate
on a base level what is it a gross
interference in your privacy or an
effective method for protecting millions
of children from sexual exploitation
well let's enter the debate
right before you go mental don't worry
i'm not a deep fake and i do exist
unfortunately i have covid so i'm
actually at home self-isolating and i
couldn't make the video for you today
uh but lucas my friend and good
colleague from some sub is happy to help
he'll be jumping in in my absence so i
hope you enjoy the video and i'll see
you in the next one luke is here your
other survival expert in the online
jungle now unfortunately i'm not bradley
wearing a deep fake as you might have
guessed i am a real person i am myself
bradley our dear dear friend the suave
brit
is unfortunately sick with coven he will
be back you will be seeing him again and
together we will be giving you the
information you need to survive online
[Music]
the new image analysis function on
mobile devices became known to the world
just a few hours before the official
announcement was heard
now matthew green a professor at john
hopkins university was one of the first
to report this new technology via
twitter
as it turned out green correctly
predicted the principle of the algorithm
that apple would use
and he even warned us about two main
problems that would appear as a result
the probability of false positives and
the abuse by the authorities the
cryptographer not only described these
threats but he even gave an example of
how the algorithm's vulnerabilities
could be exploited by hackers
how well-founded are these concerns
well to answer this question you first
need to understand how computers see
images
any parent knows that babies can
recognize faces from as little as two
months old they're able to clearly
distinguish
other people from surrounding objects
they can even try to mimic strange
facial expressions
computers on the other hand have only
learned to recognize faces and photos
quite recently
specifically at the beginning of the
2000s it was then that the ideas of the
hungarian mathematician ha which were
formulated at the beginning of the 20th
century were put into practice mit
professor paul viola together with
michael jones created an algorithm that
allows one to determine the appearance
of a face in an image
the essence of the algorithm was simple
faces of any people regardless of
nationality skin color has certain
characteristic features for example the
line of the nose is lighter than the
areas on the side the teeth are lighter
than the lips and the areas around the
eyes is darker than the forehead or the
cheeks
these light and dark aspects of the
photo are they compared with simple
geometric patterns if the pattern of a
forehead is found in the picture and
then a pattern of the nose and eyes
under them is found even lower the lips
and teeth
then we are most likely looking at a
person's face
now this algorithm doesn't require
complex calculations and at the
beginning of our century most digital
cameras began to cope with it canon
engineers first implemented the viola
jones algorithm in 2008 the algorithm
became the basis of face focusing
systems in amateur cameras
now later this technology was repeated
by other manufacturers
if you ever use such cameras you
probably have also encountered the main
problem of the algorithm it can see
faces anywhere where there are none
for example in landscapes in the facades
of buildings and such areas are called
false positives but it almost always can
identify a face
even moustached bearded or glass faces
don't interfere only bad lighting
objects in the frame that obscure the
face can make it throw out an error
the viola jones algorithm has also been
used for more complex tasks for example
it was used in early systems for
automated detection of pornographic
materials now imagine that you need to
write a program that will evaluate
photos for the presence of naughty
scenes
how can i explain to the computer that
the image is suspicious
let's have a little think about what
isn't present in adult material
clothes
most of the shots are occupied by naked
bodies or speaking in the language of
computers areas of skin color but the
color depends on the race lighting and
applied filters this is where the viola
jones algorithm comes to the rescue with
its help we first find the actors faces
find out the correct skin color from
them and then determine the areas of the
photo that these colors occupy
and then we can send all the suspicious
images for manual verification
such algorithms were very popular due to
their simplicity but unfortunately they
had a significant drawback it didn't
really detect a significant amount of
obscene pictures
if the author took the pictures with a
large number of foreign objects for
example they hid the face of the models
or they left most of the clothes on they
were not defined by the algorithm as
pornography
such areas are called false negatives
and if areas in auto focus are a minor
nuisance then saved pornographic images
can turn into real problems for the
owner of the resources into which they
are uploaded possession of such
materials can result in criminal
prosecution in both america and the
european union programmers tried to
create more advanced algorithms to
identify patents for poses and objects
to determine the content from metadata
and text descriptions
they even experimented with neural
networks and graph comparison technology
unfortunately all of these options
required significant computing resources
and they threw out a large number of
errors
so therefore more advanced mechanisms
were needed to effectively counteract
the porn industry microsoft to the
rescue
microsoft engineers took up the
development of such systems in 2009
the project was called photo dna within
the photo dna system images are not
analyzed but rather compared with an
existing database which was created by
the ncmec
now this is an abbreviation short for
the national center for missing and
exploited children this is the name of a
non-profit organization that has been
searching for missing children since
1984 and helps to overcome the
consequences of psychological and sexual
violence among young victims
the centre's digital archives contain
300 000 images containing child
pornography
this archive is called the csam child
sexual abuse materials behind each entry
is a real criminal offence and it was
these images that became the basis for
photo dna each was processed according
to a special algorithm
first it is reduced in size to its base
size and processed with brightness and
contrast filters then it switched from
color mode to grayscale the resulting
image is divided into smaller fragments
and the brightness parameters in each of
them is calculated and given a value
the result is a small string of letters
and numbers called a hash
different images have different hashes
that are unique just like your
fingerprints but copies of the same
photo will have the same hashes even if
you change its size process it with
color filters or even print it out and
scan it again another interesting
property of the hash is that it will not
be possible to recreate the original
photo from it there's just not enough
information for this
but hashes are short they're easy to
store and most importantly
easy to compare
if you want to check a suspicious photo
you will have to upload it to the system
the algorithm will calculate its hash
and compare it with the database records
if the hash matches one of them already
available on the database it means that
you've uploaded prohibited content
thus the system is not comparing the
images themselves but rather their
encoded image the system works quickly
and reliably the only drawback is that
it cannot detect unwanted content if it
is not present in the database itself
but the areas of false positives are
practically excluded in december 2014
microsoft allowed registered
organizations to use photo dna and today
most large network companies do use
these algorithms from facebook to reddit
now you may or may not have heard about
this but it doesn't change the fact that
you've probably sent photos via
instagram facebook twitter even by email
and many of those photos have been
checked by such an algorithm so why did
apple's update cause such an outcry
[Music]
[Applause]
let's find out what the love child of
jobs and wozniak is implementing
first of all it's going to be working as
protection from unwanted content on your
messenger the system will work only if
one of the participants in the dialogue
the sender or recipient of the message
is a minor
most likely the image here will be
processed by their own pornography
search algorithm
it's too early to say how it works and
how effectively it will work however i
really do like this aspect of the
technology kids often behave naively
online and i'm sure a lot of us are
guilty of sending a saucy pick or two in
our youth an extra filter here really
isn't going overboard moreover potential
areas in identifying unwanted content
don't threaten anything here if a miner
despite the warning still wants to see
questionable photos they're only rarely
threatened with an awkward conversation
from their parents
false positives don't threaten anything
we're not talking about blocking the
account here
false negatives will not differ in any
way from what is already in the
messenger
yes unwanted content can still reach the
subject but the probability is far lower
than when a filter isn't used the main
controversy is caused by the second part
of the security system
after uploading your ios version 15 a
mechanism for checking photos that you
want to upload to icloud will be added
to the system
before you begin your upload a hash is
calculated for each photo and it's then
compared with the csam database if
there's a suspicious match or two an
apple moderator will step in and check
the photos for you and if according to
the results criminal content turns out
to be on your phone
that information will be transferred to
the police
if it turns out that the algorithm works
on the principle of photo dna you have
nothing to fear even if you save your
home entertainment to the cloud system
the system is not trying to determine
whether the picture is obscene but it's
only looking for matches with images
already recognized as child pornography
the only difference from what facebook
and google have already implemented is
that an apple solution the hash of the
photo is calculated on your phone or
tablet instead of on the server of
another company
for me this isn't really important yes
the probability of a random match of
hashes for different photos you know
cannot mathematically be excluded
but it does remain extremely low
unless of course we are talking about
deliberately fabricated images
this is theoretically possible as
professor grin showed us by his twitter
the only problem is that the
cryptographer from baltimore
used a simplified algorithm
what he did was create a bright but
extremely limited model in real photos
matching hashes will occur much less
often than matching fingerprints for
example
theoretically possible practically
i don't think so
so what is this panic really about has
it been caused by the technological
ignorance of the populace unfortunately
no the real threat is hidden in the
database itself theoretically it can
include not only pornography but for
example extremist symbols or portraits
of leaders of religious movements
anything else that can identify your
affiliation to certain organizations and
movements well surely this is unlikely
to happen the truth is the algorithm has
actually already been used this way
before
back in 2016 facebook twitter google and
microsoft used photo dna technology to
limit the distribution of al-qaeda
videos the companies began to exchange
hashes of photos and videos that had
terrorists in them those that described
a recruitment of militants or even those
that referenced the word of holy war or
jihad
sure we can agree that international
terrorism is evil but if we look at
society nowadays i'm afraid to imagine
who might be declared a terrorist in the
next couple of decades
in the end this decision by apple is
final users are not asked whether they
want to make the world a little bit
better but they are driven into a brave
new world with the iron fist of apple
futuristic dystopia anyone
well to resist this you could just
refuse to use icloud or switch your
phone's data to another smartphone
sooner or later other manufacturers are
going to fall in line behind their
monopolistic masters and in the end
you'll have to forget about privacy in
the same way that you forgot about the
headphone jack
no more passing the auxiliary cord to
your friend in the front seat to dj
courtesy of appalling anyway my name is
lucas newman your down under survival
instructor in the digital jungle please
share your thoughts and doubts about new
technology in the comments below and i
promise here at some subs channel i'll
tell you what is not worth being afraid
of and what is really a hidden threat
may the knowledge be with you
[Music]
you